[Musique]
la suite des débats en vue du premier
tour des élections municipales prévues
le 15 mars prochain bienvenue si vous
nous rejoignez sur tv 78 également l
radio sensations yvelines et nous
accueillons pour cette émission les
candidats à voisins le bretonneux au 22
février trois listes sont officiellement
déclarés et vont débattre de leurs
programmes en plateau alexandra rosetti
maire sortante udi de la commune tête de
liste et d'alexandra rosetti 2020 à côté
de vous béatrice pierrât pour avec vous
voisin avance et olivier afonso qui
conduit unis pour voisin bonjour à tous
les trois merci d'avoir répondu
favorablement à notre invitation je
rappelle que pour ce débat elle est
temps de parole seront chronométrés et
s'afficheront régulièrement durant cette
émission et je précise aussi qu'un
tirage au sort a été effectué pour
déterminer l'ordre des temps de parole
pour débuter ce débat et c'est vous
alexandra rosetti qui a les a débuté
candidate pour un deuxième mandat votre
liste est soutenu par la république en
marche lui dei et le modem
vous êtes élu dans la commune depuis
2001 vous êtes maire depuis 2014 et vous
avez été réélu en 2015 lors d'une
nouvelle élection municipale un rendu
nécessaire après un recours également
vice présidente de l'agglomération de
saint quentin en yvelines en charge de
l'aménagement du territoire pourquoi
être de nouveau candidate pour cette
élection
bonjour et bien parce qu'un mandat de
maire ça peut sembler non mais en mer
fait six ans et c'est assez court
surtout comme vous l'avez rappelé il ya
une petite interruption au démarrage
on a mis un certain nombre de projets en
route donc j'aimerais bien et mener à
leur terme
et puis aussi faire bénéficier aux vices
in web de l'expérience que j'ai acquis
pendant pendant ces six ans justement
avec mes collègues de l'agglomération où
je pense avoir beaucoup appris et puis
également avec ce que j'ai pu vivre au
département olivier afonso vous êtes
cadre financier lui d'opposition depuis
2015 à voisins le bretonneux tête de
liste je le rappel du nid pour voisin
candidatures de droite que vous portez
avec
thiery gastaud qui était aussi face à
vous lors de l'élection en 2015
l'élection municipale partielle même
question que pour les autres pourquoi
être candidat et pourquoi être candidat
tête de liste
d'abord je suis candidat parce que
j'estime que sur des projets
structurants pour notre ville nous
n'avons pas répondu présent je suis
candidat parce que je pense que le cadre
de vie aujourd'hui aux voisins se
dégrade et qu'il nous faut maintenant
répondre à des urgences comme l'arrivée
de la gare comme l'urbanisme on va en
parler ce soir
moi j'ai surtout envie de parler donc
d'avenir plus que tu passais vous dire
que j'ai constitué une équipe composée
d'élus d'anciens élus majoritairement
des personnes qui viennent de la société
civile j'ai six jeunes qui m'accompagne
de 18 à 25 ans qui apporte un un
dynamisme étonnant dans cette campagne
j'ai construit avec eux un projet
cohérent crédible
j'ai fait des propositions dès le départ
dès le début de ma campagne sur les
sujets comme la circulation le vivre
ensemble
donc je pense qu'aujourd'hui et bien il
ya une nécessité d'avoir un projet un
cap une vision pour notre ville avoir
une équipe mobilisée et avoir un maire
investi pleinement dans et pour sa
commune béatrice sépia ans termine ce
premier tour de table avec vous vous
êtes tête de liste d' avec vos voisins
avance avance pardon une liste de centre
gauche sur laquelle figurent notamment
des élus municipaux dont en numéro deux
jean hache qui a été déjà candidat dans
la ville il s'agit pour vous de votre
première campagne politique pour vous
donc y être salarié dans l'industrie
pourquoi être candidat pour quoi vous
engager dans cette démarche bonjour
grégory canal et pourquoi s'engager
parce que nous pensons jeudi nous parce
que nous sommes une équipe sur la liste
vous avez mentionné jean h il ya
également d'autres personnes qui sont
aujourd'hui élu nous pensons qu'il est
nécessaire d'offrir une alternative aux
deux listes de droite qui viennent de se
présenter avec une vision plus axé sur
la transition est coresponsable mais
également sur une ville citoyenne à
l'écouté de tous est aussi une ville
solidaire donc les trois piliers que
nous défendons dans cette campagne
alors coup d'oeil sur les temps de
parole avant de poursuivre vous êtes à
30 secondes béatrice pirates tout comme
alexandra rosetti une minute de temps de
parole pour olivier affonso avant de
poursuivre regardons ce sujet qui résume
les principaux enjeux pour la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux lors de ces
élections municipales et le point est
fait avec manou varaldo voisins le
bretonneux compte 11000 426 habitants en
2020 mais elle a perdu 1000 habitants en
15 ans malgré la production de 590
logement ces dernières années à voisins
le bretonneux les projets immobiliers se
succèdent 29 logements dans le centre 95
logements dans le quartier du lac ou
encore 110 logements à la grande île des
projets vont également sortir de terre
c'est le cas à rue hélène boucher et 18
logements vont voir le jour à prévoir
pour 2022 sur ce terrain vague la
construction de l'écoquartier la zone
d'aménagement concerté du quartier et de
la remise contrat sans logement avec
notamment un parc arboré et des jardins
partagés voisins le bretonneux n'a que
18,5 % de logements sociaux contre 25 %
exigés par l'état d'ici 2025
le point noir la circulation à voisins
le bretonneux lieu de transit entre la
vallée de chevreuse et saint quentin en
yvelines
les carrefours sont des points de
ralentissements en heure de pointe en
jeu également le nouveau cimetière le
projet de construction d'un troisième
cimetière à la place du square des 40
arpents a été contestée un collectif
s'est constitué pour s'opposer à sa
création
après ce mouvement de contestation deux
autres terrains potentiels sont à
l'étude ou en passe de l'être
enfin autre inquiétude pour les piscines
ou à la moitié des médecins généralistes
partent bientôt à la retraite et ne
prennent pas de nouveaux patients pour
pallier cette pénurie les habitants
attendent une maison de santé
pluriprofessionnelle elle devrait être
construite à l'emplacement de l'ancien
leader price au centre de la grande île
et des généralistes et spécialistes sont
recherchés voilà pour ces enjeux dont
nous allons développer une bonne partie
au cours de ce débat le premier thème la
circulation voisins le bretonneux
s'était dit dans ce sujet est au
carrefour de la vallée de chevreuse et
de l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines dont elle fait partie la
commune est donc fortement impacté par
des problèmes de trafic de transit
plusieurs dizaines de milliers de
véhicules qui passent par la ville
chaque jour il ya forcément un enjeu
pour le cadre de vie mais aussi pour
l'environnement alexandra rosetti je me
tourne vers vous alors durant votre
mandat il ya des choses qui ont été
tentées pour tenter d'endiguer ce
problème vous avez organisé une
concertation sur cette thématique
imaginait aussi des projets notamment
cela a été évoqué un projet de
contournement par le sud de
voisins-le-bretonneux avec qui nécessite
elle à la réouverture d'une ancienne
voie communale un projet qui a suscité
une vive opposition dans votre conseil
municipal mais aussi dans la commune
voisine voisins le bretonneux il ya eu
un échange voilà donc on va dire de
tension en tout cas entre avec le maire
de voisins-le-bretonneux de manille de
magny les hameaux vous êtes la mère de
voisins-le-bretonneux merci quels sont
les autres pistes que auquel vous pensez
pour endiguer ce problème de la
circulation alors d'abord le projet de
contournement il n'a pas fait l'objet
d'une vive opposition au sein du conseil
la difficulté de ce projet qu'on a
essayé de repoussé parce que le pousser
à nouveau pardon
effectivement c'est que c'est sans doute
la meilleure solution c'est à dire avoir
une voix qui partirait sur magny les
hameaux et qui arriveraient pas ce qu'on
appelle le rond-point hilti d'autant
plus que dans quelques années nous
aurons la garde de la ligne 18 qui sera
gérée dans le prolongement de ce rond
point dans le coeur qui sera situé
géographiquement sur le territoire
libyen en cours mais qui est maintenant
sera voisin proche de voisins donc c'est
vrai que ça pouvait avoir du sens donc
nous avons nous avons essayé de vrai en
ce sens et c'est vrai que nous nous
sommes heurtés principalement mais pas
seulement au maire de magny les hameaux
très bien il ya chez lui on peut le
comprendre donc nous avons également
fait une expérimentation pendant pendant
ce mandat puisque au fait
le noeud du problème se situe sur
différents carrefours à l'entrée de
voisins champ du loup un petit peu plus
loin sur le carrefour des pyramides au
carrefour suivant de lui en course et ce
jusqu à guyancourt donc le problème
n'est pas qu'à voisin salaires qui se
poursuit jusqu'à lui en cours les autres
villes
les autres listes de sortie de la vallée
de chevreuse dans les mêmes soucis
mais le ministre denis château fort à
sont embouteillées tous les matins parce
qu'on parle surtout évidemment de
circulation de transit le matin et dans
le centre ville
donc il faut arriver à redonner un petit
peu de fluidité donc nous avons fait une
expérimentation à un carrefour en
changeant les phases de feu qui nous a
permis de voir que effectivement
fluidifier mais que ça mettait en jeu la
sécurité en particulier des piétons et
les cyclistes
donc nous avons arrêté cette
expérimentation est le saint quentin est
le département qui sont les départements
c'est une départementale 50 ans est
pleinement impliqué dans la mobilité
donc ça en train de retravailler à
d'autres solutions mais c'est forcément
être une collaboration avec les autres
collectivités
l'utilisation peut pas toutes façons on
n'a pas de dépendance pour agir tout
seul mais l'enseignement que ça nous a
donné c'est que trop fluidifier n'est
pas forcément la meilleure chose à faire
lors c il faut arriver en fait à trouver
un compromis
comment dire à répartir les flux le plus
équitablement possible entre les
différentes des différentes voies
sachant que notre problème principal en
fait c'est la route qui arrive de magny
les hameaux qui passe devant une école
de voisins et qui donc le matin
effectivement potentiellement peut
amener du danger et puis aussi bien sûr
de la pollution donc c'est un problème
assez assez inextricables je vais dire
parce que quand vous touchez un endroit
vous en impact est un autre et donc il
faut trouver un équilibre
voilà et je suis pas moins favorable à
attirer trop tiffin a beaucoup
fluidifier cet axe là puisqu'on
attirerait davantage de circulation
puisque grâce au gps collaboratif on
sait très bien où il faut passer
voilà dès que des bouchons olivier
affonso la circulation est l'un des axes
majeurs de votre campagne vous souhaitez
fluidifier les grands axes grâce à la
création notamment de tunnels mettre en
place aussi une nouvelle sortie sur la
rd 36 ou encore à développer le débat le
déplacement propres à l'intérieur de la
commune qu'elles sont
quels sont les propriétaires il ya
plusieurs plusieurs il ya plusieurs le
dernier sujet ce que vous évoquez c'est
l'aide que nous voulons mettre en place
pour les les les personnes âgées les
aînés qui sont loin du centre-ville âge
et on veut mettre en place des navettes
comme il existe dans plusieurs villes
donc ça c'est un autre projet laissez la
circulation à l'intérieur de la commune
exactement bon sur la circulation
c'est un sujet extrêmement complexe mais
il faut bien reconnaître qu'on a bien
perdu 6 ans sur ce sujet on nous avait
dit qu'on ferait le contournement par le
sud
on s'est opposé enfin on le maire de
manille a découvert accidentellement qui
avaient un projet qui se vantait on a
fait rêver les vies si noah sur un
projet c'est triste parce que moi je
suis tout à fait d'accord pour le mettre
en place mais il ne se fera jamais c'est
une certitude n'a pas découvert
accidentellement on est allé le voir à
écouter vu les réactions sur facebook vu
sa réaction violente vis-à-vis davis
c'est pas du tout à fait ce qui est mal
aisé mais pour terminer
moi ce que je regrette c'est que quand
on prend des engagements il faut pouvoir
les tenir ou tout du moins expliquer
officines mois pour qu'on les tient pas
moi je me souviens en 2014 votre acte
des solutions pertinentes existent pour
pour maîtriser l'entrée des flux moi
j'attends vos solutions pertinentes
vous venez de faire un constat je
partage totalement votre constat à une
différence près j'ai toujours
l'impression que le département n'a pas
vraiment envie d'agir pour nous aider
parce qu'on sert de zone tampon et ça
permet de fluidifier ailleurs mais
aujourd'hui moi je connais pas votre
position
on constate vous en tout cas vos
propositions on parle par exemple de la
mise en place de qu elle est ce que
c'est réalisable sur le plan financier
on c'est réalisable c'est pas un pouvoir
c'est c'est pas le pouvoir c'est vouloir
le faire aujourd'hui c'est un problème
politique
notre histoire de circulation l'arrivée
de la gare est formidable c'est un atout
formidable parce que pour accéder à la
guerre bat fort quand même passé par
voisins donc il va falloir que les
départements m
la poche la région si vous l'avez pas
dit en entrée de débat mais la
présidente de la région ile de france
soutient ma liste la candidature donc
aujourd'hui c'est pas le fait de pouvoir
c'est le fait de vouloir nous on a fait
des propositions des mini tunnels
servent la rue de la mérantaise qui est
une rue où il va falloir faire des
aménagements sérieux parce que je ne
peux pas admettre que les enfants soient
obligés de se déporter sur la route
parce que les trottoirs ne sont pas aux
normes
vous avez aussi le carrefour qui réunit
les trois les trois villes où il va
falloir faire quelque chose pour
sécuriser donc on a fait des
propositions
donc aujourd'hui il s'agit de fluidifier
les grands axes vous l'avais dit la rue
de la mérantaise est ma priorité et je
veux aussi parler de la circulation
douce parce que les pistes cyclables à
voisins ont été développées certes mais
y en a certaines qui sont profondément
dangereuse donc je ferai un audit sur
sur ces pistes cyclables et je considère
qu'il faut absolument dans les nouveaux
projets immobiliers imposer des pistes
cyclables une circulation douce
béatrice pira je vous donne la parole de
ce que vous êtes à 30 secondes
actuellement vous parlez vous aussi de
circulation dans vos axes prioritaires
alors pour vous les décisions doivent
être prises en accord avec les habitants
et en faveur de l'environnement
les solutions que vous évoquez c'est de
promouvoir alors ça c'est pour le
transport à l'intérieur de
voisins-le-bretonneux le transport inter
urbain ça c'est pas renoncer pour elle
et pour les solutions de transport sur
les différentes communes à l'inter de
voisins je vais y arriver ce sont des
solutions par exemple mettre en place un
plan vélo un plan marche ces solutions
que vous évoquez est tout à fait
j'entends ce qui vient d'être dit
concernant la une circulation plus
fluide nous pensons qu une circulation
plus fluide entraîne également une
augmentation de trafic parce que comme
il a été dit aujourd'hui il existe des
outils qui permettent de voir quel est
le meilleur parcours en fonction des
temps et fluidifier la circulation dans
voisins risquent d'entraîner aussi une
augmentation de cette circulation qui
aujourd'hui est vécue par les vices et
noise et lévis sinois comme à un souci
un souci effectivement liés à la
pollution mais aussi liées à la sécurité
des différentes personnes qui peuvent
traverser la ville ce que nous pensons
c'est que la solution vis-à-vis du parc
naturel de chevreuse doit passer par une
concertation avec l'agglomération carla
réponse doit être globale et collégial
et qu'on doit effectivement aussi
promouvoir un plan marche et un plan
vélo avec une continuité des pistes
cyclables sécurisées comme l'a dit
olivier afonso bien sûr l'enjeu de la
sécurité est toujours présent de façon à
réduire le trafic à l'intérieur de la
ville enfin vous étiez avant de passer à
un autre thème voulait serrer qu'on dise
que moi je suis un peu un petit peu
surprise puisque votre interview
monsieur alfonso vous avez expliqué que
si vous étiez maire pendant six ans vous
alliez effectivement observé ce qui se
passe avant de proposer des solutions
donc leur procès oui me reprocher à moi
de d'avoir perdu du temps je suis pas
absolument pas d'accord sur le sujet des
tunnels moi j'ai fait regarder ça
évidemment donc techniquement si ce
n'est pas faisable en fait c'est pas
comme l'expert qu'il ya cinq ans c'est
donc ce n'est pas le flacon monsieur
alfonso c'est vrai que le département
est contre nous donc sa cavale et
chaleureuse vous aide et le département
contre nous je ne comprends pas tout
mais c'est pas grave les tunnels ça ne
fonctionnera pas parce que d'un point de
vue technique il faudrait que vous
d'oublier la venue de la pyramide bien
en amont pour pouvoir plonger ensuite il
ya un rayon de giration qui est quand
même assez important ressortirez
replonger tout de suite ce n'est pas
possible techniquement donc les bonnes
idées de monsieur van de waal j'ai pas
de souci avec ça sauf que là ça ne
fonctionnera pas et si jamais ça
fonctionnait vous créez une autoroute à
l'intérieur deux voisins voulaient
attirer énormément de circulation donc
moi je ne peux pas être pour ça donc de
dire que je n'ai rien fait comme en six
ans c'est faux puisque nous quand nous
avons fait l'expérimentation
vous m'avez même raillé parce que
c'était amusant apparemment mais au
moins ça nous a permis d'aboutir à des
conclusions pour pour ce qui est du pour
ce qui est du vélo alors pour la rue de
la mérantaise effectivement alors vous
parlez la rue la menteuse nord parce que
la mer monte suite à bien des trottoirs
aux normes elle a été refaite au début
du mandat et la mer en techno nous
sommes en train de travailler vous le
savez depuis à peu près 9 9 10 mois sur
la question avec les riverains en
concertation avec les riverains et on se
concerte en ce qui concerne les vélos ce
que nous avons fait en terme de
déplacement cyclable dans la vie nous
l'avons fait que l'association vélo ski
qui me semble-t-il est une association
il a plus à même de nous expliquer donc
par exemple sur la review fleurs c'est
elle qui nous a conseillé de mettre à
faire passer il doit à contresens par
exemple mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on travaille surtout pas seuls et le
département nous accompagne bien
évidemment dans toutes non juste avant
de vous laisser répond je voulais parce
que vous avez un petit peu de retard
béatrice pire assure la par exemple la
solution évoquée des tunnels qu'est ce
que vous en pensez
j'en pense qu'il ya des personnes qui
sont tout à fait en charge des sujets
d'aménagement du territoire et que une
étude est nécessaire je ne me
prononcerai pas au nom de notre liste
sur ce plateau ce soir
ne connaissant pas le détail du sujet
comme nous le défendons dans notre liste
nous pensons qu'il faut demander aux
personnes concernées donc aux habitants
quelle est leur avis il ya une étude qui
a été faite par le conseil de quartier
centre village l'année dernière sur le
sujet de la circulation je pense qu'il
faut tenir compte des remarques qui sont
faites par les habitants et
effectivement comme l'a dit aussi
alexandra rosetti tenir compte des
impératifs techniques parce qu'on est
dans une zone qui est quand même assez
réduite en terme d' espaces donc il faut
trouver des solutions qui sont concrètes
et pérennes pour tous olivia congo en
une minute pour que les temps de parole
soit plutôt équilibré non moi je suis
ravi qu'on discute de mon projet je suis
ravi qu'on discute de mes propositions
mais je n'ai toujours pas de proposition
en face sur le sujet de la circulation
il faudra discuter avec les maires des
villes voisines c'est une certitude
moi je constate madame rosetti que vous
êtes dans le statu quo et vous ne voulez
pas avancer ce sujet je voudrais
simplement précisé un dernier point
quand je vois que sur le site internet
du département 30 projets on parle quand
même de projets comme par exemple un
tunnel à montesson par exemple une voie
nouvelle à sartrouville à montesson pour
100 millions d'euros financés par le
département le département allait fille
a les moyens financiers j'ai pas parlé
tine a les moyens financiers étaient
donc ce qui est valable
ce qui est valable à trappes par exemple
l enfouissement il dit
dévoiement des réseaux ce qui est
valable à montesson avec la mise en
place de tunnels vous dit clairement que
vous ne souhaitez pas con
et met en place à voisins c'est votre
droit et je terminerai et je terminerai
par rapport vous dire que ça fait des
mois et des mois que nous faisons des
propositions j'ai fait avec thierry
gastou et monsieur jean h une conférence
de presse commune où nous n'étions pas
forcément d'accord ensemble sur les
sujets sur les solutions pardon mais par
contre nous avions toujours dit que nous
étions prêts travaillent avec vous ce
qui n'a toujours pas été le cas et j'ai
été ravi d'apprendre par la presse que
vous étiez je me souviens très bien de
ce moment je me suis dit j'apprends par
la presse que voulait travailler avec
moi j'ai trouvé ça j'ai trouvé que
c'était un grand moment pour tout y est
passé à la deuxième thématique et
regarder tout de suite les temps de
parole alexandra rose et si vous êtes à
5 minutes 27 secondes olivier affonso
quatre minutes 46 secondes
béatrice pire à vous avez un petit peu
de retard dans ce débat donc je vais
vous donner la parole à vous pour
commencer alors sur ce deuxième thème
qui est l'urbanisation avec forcément
plusieurs problématiques
on a évoqué cette gare de la ligne 18 de
saint quentin est qu'ils arrivent sur la
commune de guyancourt et qui est juste
tout proche et de la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux il faut donc
réfléchir à terme sur ce pôle gare qui
arrive sur ce territoire problématique
également en termes de logements sociaux
18 5 % de logements sociaux à voisins le
bretonneux avec un objectif fixé par
l'état à 25% d'ici 2025 sans quoi il y
aura des pénalités à payer est aussi une
perte de population c'est une autre
problématique à voisins le bretonneux
près de 1000 habitants la commune a
perdu près de 1000 habitants sur ces
dernières années béatrice pira pour vous
le maître mot sur l'urbanisation c'est
prendre du recul
il faut penser ses projets avec du recul
pour le futur favoriser aussi des
solutions durables en matière
d'éclairage écologique voilà c'est le
genre de proposition vous pouvez faire
et aussi alors ça c'est une autre
proposition développer des solutions de
logements modulables et et solidaire
c'est ça
comme vous l'avait dit et comme c'était
précisé dans votre reportage la
population de la ville des croix nous
pensons qu'il faut renforcer
l'attractivité de la ville et notamment
faire venir des jeunes familles soit des
couples qui n'ont pas encore d'enfant
soit des jeunes familles pour revoir
aussi l' équilibre de la population dans
la ville pour ce faire ce que nous
constatons sur voisins le bretonneux
mais c'est le cas des différentes villes
de l'agglomération c'est que le prix du
foncier est élevé ce qui fait que des
personnes vont aussi en vallée de
chevreuse et traverse aussi notre vélin
revient en premier sujet et donc pour
trouver des solutions par rapport à ce
foncier nous avons regardé ce qui était
fait nous avons vu des exemples
notamment dans les villes de rennes dont
je parlais lundi soir dans le programme
enfin dans l'interview avec votre
confrère est aussi dans la ville de
lille où en fait il y a des outils qui
permettent de séparer le foncier du bâti
pour réduire le prix d'acquisition des
logements de l'ordre de 20 à 40%
c'est une des pistes que nous souhaitons
travailler et puis il ya aussi le plan
local habitat qui était votée sur une
période de 2018 à 2023 et qui doit être
déroulé être mises en oeuvre
effectivement pour favoriser
l'habitation dans notre vie mais il y
autre chose alors vous souhaitez
transformer voire 30 ans mes voisins de
villes villages à vie urbaine qu'est ce
que ça veut dire concrètement voisin
s'intègre dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines
c'est effectivement un village au sens
où il est proche du parc naturel
de la haute vallée de chevreuse la merci
mais c'est aussi une ville qui va voir
arriver la ligne 18 et il est nécessaire
d'intégrer tous ces nouveaux enjeux dans
un délai relativement proche en parle de
2030 donc le prochain mandat va
s'étendre jusqu'à 2026 donc il faut
commencer à se mettre en trajectoire
pour intégrer ces nouveaux enjeux et
transformer la ville
alors quand je dis transformer intégrer
une partie urbaine à la ville parce
qu'il est clair que les quartiers
pavillonnaires restaurant pavillonnaire
avec sandra rosetti alors ce grand
projet de la ligne 18 qui va arriver
tout proche de voisins-le-bretonneux
grands projets au silence et c'est l'éco
quartier de la remise qui va accueillir
500 logements
le maître d'ouvragé a été choisi les
promoteurs du grand paris c'est le grand
projet à porter pour pour les prochaines
années à voisins-le-bretonneux oui alors
c'est vrai ça fait 20 ans qu'on dit je
suis quand même donc je suis ravi de le
faire aboutir en tout cas ce sera un
écoquartier donc qui devra être
exemplaire en particulier dans le
l'isolation et dans le mode de chauffage
des différents bâtiments et puis c'est
un quartier lui à 55% des espaces verts
un hectare de bois qui sera replanté
avec un concept de parc habité donc
c'est un très beau projet qui
accueillera des logements en accession
libre des logements sociaux et des
logements en accession en accession
aidée
effectivement je suis d'accord avec
madame pierrât le bail réel solidaire le
brs c'est une vraie solution pour
voisins le bretonneux
c'est ce qui va nous permettre
d'atteindre 25 % de logements sociaux un
petit peu plus vite que prévu je dirais
puisque c'est un produit qui sait de
l'accession à la propriété sociale et ça
reste dans le contingent des logements
sociaux de la ville contrairement à ce
qui se fait actuellement en accession
aidée
donc je trouve que c'est plutôt positif
parce que ça répond à un besoin de nous
nous avons besoin d'attirer des jeunes
familles moi c'est très souvent que les
jeunes me disent mais on ne peut pas on
ne peut pas acheter à voisins n'en a pas
les moyens
et juste peut-être rapidement si sur ce
sujet il ne faut surtout pas prendre les
exigences de l'état à la légère
dieme une exigence 25 % en 2025
aujourd'hui je ne sais pas y arriver je
vous rassure tout de suite c'est un
petit peu compliqué c'est non seulement
une pénalité qui peut être multiplié par
5 c'est à dire de passer de 130 mille
euros à près de 700000 euros
et puis c'est également la perte de la
délivrance des permis qui peut être
faite par le préfet qu'il a commencé à
le faire dans d'autres villes justement
pour donner des exemples
olivia présent sur cette thématique de
l'urbanisation vous souhaitez davantage
préserver les espaces verts revoir aussi
le calendrier des programmes immobiliers
dans la commune
conditionner la construction de nouveaux
logements à la réalisation d'équipements
c'est ce qui fait partie de huy 1300
logements qui vont arriver dans moins de
cinq ans à peu près si je fais le compte
je veux terminer n'ont aucune
infrastructure nouvelle on n'adapte pas
les infrastructures on recommence les
mêmes erreurs du passé alors soyons
clair parce que j'entends ici ou là des
rumeurs aient compris quand vous les
propager sur votre facebook live pour ce
qui me concerne les choses sont claires
il va falloir construire à voisins nous
avons besoin de logements ne participe à
la commission logement je vois bien
qu'il ya un besoin
il n'est pas normal que nos jeunes ne
puisse pas rester sur voisin parce que
c'est extrêmement cher donc il va
falloir construire ne faisons pas peur
sur les 25 % c'est l'objectif ça n'est
pas ça n'est pas sur la zone dit il je
suis pas venu faire un show je suis venu
pour parler de l'avenir de l'allemagne
non plus bon donc je vous dis simplement
que nous avons 25 % à atteindre
on le sait c'est très compliqué mais
c'est bien l'objectif il faut respecter
la loi même si je suis maire de voisins
je respecterai la loi soyez rassurés
nous avons je pense une chance
historique
honnêtement c'est la gare parce que la
future gare il va y avoir un certain
bien je crois plus de 2000 logements qui
sont prévues mais c'est surtout 130
mille ou cent quarante mille mètres
carrés de zones d'activités cette zone
d'activités avoir une conséquence
importante sur la vie économique de
voisins on le voit le parc
duval 50 ans aujourd'hui c'est une zone
où il ya pas mal de bureau il ya 40 % de
bureaux qui sont vides aujourd'hui moi
je propose de transformer ses 40 % en
zone d'habitat l'avantagé que vous avez
le la rd86 et la rd 91 qui bordent cette
zone là ce qui fait que nous avons les
infrastructures qui peuvent accueillir
ces logements
c'est une proposition que je fais
pourquoi parce qu'aujourd'hui on est en
train d'urbaniser le centre village
comme jamais je note que nous allons
faire pour la première fois je crois
voisin un programme 100% logements
sociaux sur la souleva l'apprenez voilà
vous n'avez pas les bons enseignements
c'est une deuxième fois puisque le maire
joseph réticents pour s'annoncer pas
100% il ya des maisons individuelles en
accession aidée je vais vous parler du
mes rentes ai je serais heureux vous en
parler parce que la remise je suis pas
tout à fait d'accord avec vous un
écoquartier c'est d'abord le bien vivre
des gens je ne suis pas convaincu qu'on
construire 500 logements sur 5 ha parce
que ça n'est pas sur dix est à ce que
vous construisez sur une bande vous
allez mettre des immeubles en face de
zones pavillonnaires
ah oui c'est vrai vous les êtes allez
donc vous voulez supprimer le parc non
madame rosine amené soyez clair il fut
un temps son âme rosetti soit on essaie
de débattre tranquillement ils rataient
pas je vous demande si vous détenez vous
non je suis en train d'imprimer ou
obèses noirs attentes et je suis un
chrétien mais s'étendent et les autres
je suis à fond au tennessee
mademoiselle kg sera répondu à ces
formes non mais c'est simple alesi
mesure je ne suis pas le maire sortant
ça vous a pas échappé ce que je suis en
train de vous dire c'est que mettre des
immeubles en face de zones
pavillonnaires
ce n'est pas la coutume de voisins ou
parodie mais rente ai il était prévu une
époque effectivement d'avoir lui-même
l'immeuble en face des maisons d'alfred
de vigny mais vos prédécesseurs l'a très
vite compris puisqu'elle y a lui aussi
ce collectif qui s'est créé et
l'immeuble a été déporté nous avons nous
ont fait nous allons et alexandre
horizon on laissera la parole à béatrice
pire à kia dur d'en haut lieu julien je
dis que je souhaite étendre la vita sur
le parc d'affaires du val saint quentin
transformer ce parc qui est un endroit
magnifique en un véritable éco quartier
je veux que nous gardons la maîtrise de
l'urbanisation ça veut dire qu'il faut
donc essayer de respecter tant bien que
mal les 25%
mais de là à faire n'importe quoi comme
je vois actuellement canton
transforme le plan local d'urbanisme
pour pouvoir intégrer un projet d'un
promoteur tous ceux qui sont attachés à
la ferme royer aujourd'hui on voit ce
projet ça leur fait mal au coeur
donc nous avons aujourd'hui à renouer
aussi avec un véritable concertation
moi si je suis élu maire je ne ferai pas
une réunion le soir sur un projet alors
que le permis de construire a été
déposée le matin même même rosetti très
rapidement vous êtes très rapidement
c'est compliqué parce que là il ya
vraiment beaucoup de choses qui sont
absolument fausses mais vraiment alors
1300 logements alors a jusqu'à présent
vous écriviez milles alors qu'on est en
dessous de 1000 maintenant vous êtes
amusant non mais laissez moi finir du
cours d'eau frémissante peut-être c'est
vrai que c'est vrai que vous avez écrit
un tract parfaitement mensonger vous
expliquez que je vais faire 400
logements dans dans une zone vous savez
moi monsieur alfonso contrairement à
vous du coup je suis pour l'emploi donc
supprimés supprimer des entreprises pour
faire de logements c'est supprimer le
long du rhin
c'est supprimer ça veut pas dire qu'ils
vont rester vides moi j'estime que nous
avons besoin d'activités et d'emplois
donc vous fait une proposition c'est
très bien moi ce que j'aimerais savoir
alors sur le coup du dépôt de permis de
construire non puisque nous avons adopté
comme principe qu'on ait déposé pas de
permis de construire tant que nous
n'avions pas vu les riverains je vous
signale que je n'ai aucun recours sur
aucun programme immobilier
sauf par des opposants qui n'ont pas
d'intérêt à agir et cela peut cela
démontre que nous travaillons avec les
riverains très en amont
ça c'est une première chose vraiment
rapidement aller c'est si difficile de
répondre à tout ça aussi rapidement en
tout cas ce que j'aimerais savoir c'est
ce que monsieur à fond son forfait ferai
lorsque des promoteurs que lorsque des
privés vendre à des promoteurs ou centre
ville je voudrais juste signaler pour
terminer que je suis dans le pays est
lui qui est révisée en ce moment sur
lequel nous avons réduit la
constructibilité en centre-ville
nous avons réduit l'emprise au sol
monsieur à fond c'est monsieur gaston
voté contre
voilà des liens je vais devoir donner la
parole à me pierrât on va avancer pas
lui je précise juste que c'est le plan
local d'urbanisme intercommunal même
pire à un dernier mot sur l'écologie
vous avez cinq minutes de retard sur
alexandra rosetti il ya notamment une
idée vous portez c'est celle de
mettre en place des boulevards urbains
c'est ça aa voisins le bretonneux
boulevard urbain ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire que quand on veut favoriser la
circulation douce à pied ou en vélo il
faut que cette circulation soit agréable
aujourd'hui on passe dans des zones qui
ne sont pas toujours agréables et l'idée
est de d'avoir quelque chose d'agréable
donc des bâtiments avec des commerces
quelque chose qui s'apparente à ce qu'on
voit dans les grandes métropoles je
pense à à paris alors bien sûr on n'est
pas à de la taille de paris mais avoir
des bâtiments plus humain qui donne
envie de se promener en fait on va
passer à une autre thématique ce que le
temps avance dans ce débat un sujet qui
est forcément lié à celui de l'urbanisme
c'est la question du nouveau cimetière
et en paroles qui s'affichent neuf
minutes de temps de parole pour les
sandra rosetti béatrice pire à 4 minutes
53 vous aurez forcément une plus longue
conclusions à la fin de ce débat et
olivier affonso vous êtes à 8 minutes 17
le cimetière construction d'un troisième
cimetière qui est en projet dans la
commune pour accueillir 467 culture un
temps envisagée à l'emplacement du
square des 40 arpents le nouveau site
devra se construire ailleurs ensuite au
combat d'un collectif qui était opposé à
ce projet déjà alexandra vous étiez où
en est le projet s'il ya d'autres pistes
aujourd'hui s'insurge sur la table oui
comme je m'y suis engagée il ya d'autres
il ya d'autres terrains qui sont
envisagées juste on est dans la tente de
la rs qui doit nommer un hydrogéologue
agréé et qui sera plus à même de nous
dire quels sont les quelles sont les
meilleures les meilleurs terrains donc
c'est un petit peu et puis ensuite mais
on engagera la concertation qui a tendu
pour les habitants juste deux choses
quoi qu'on fasse on est obligé de le
faire à voisins ce n'est pas possible de
faire un cimetière intercommunal gelé
vérifier puisque je suis pas je suis pas
têtu dans goûter aux côtes
je j'ai demandé autour de moi ou
communes alentour et donc forcément ce
sera sur un espace vert et forcément ce
sera proche d'habitations puisque tous
les terrains disponibles sont dans cette
configuration on va faire un seul tour
de table olivier afonso pour vous il
faut repenser ce projet de nous insulter
on n'a pas le temps non on n'a pas le
temps ça n'a pas été anticipée ça a été
fait à la va vite
il faut agir donc aujourd'hui juste pour
répondre aux eti sur le plan local
d'urbanisme puisque c'est lié au
cimetière quand on veut faire un passage
en force il faut pas s'étonner
qui est quelque part de la résistance
vous avez voulu voter rhdp lui en
imposant le site du cimetière au score
des 40 arpents
c'est une décision complètement
irréfléchi et pas très rationnel puisque
l'équipe majoritaire avait prévu dans le
plan local d'urbanisme d'intégrer ce
cimetière au champ du loup
on a fait une réunion en commission oui
ça c'était avant oui sauf comme
d'ailleurs comme tous les sujets
actuellement on fait une réunion tout
semble acté et finalement changement
changement de pied on décide le square
des 40 arpents
on vote une délibération le 13 novembre
pas une étude qui démontre la
faisabilité du projet pas une étude un
petit croquis ont le vote le 28 novembre
quelques jours plus tard madame rosetti
vient feynoord fait organiser une
réunion un peu en catimini pour tout
vous dire
et finalement elle se rend compte que ba
son choix qu'elle souhaite imposer n'est
pas n'est pas partagé par tout le monde
et madame rosetti s'est engagé
effectivement un faire une étude
différents endroits donc aujourd'hui il
faut choisir je ne suis pas partisan
si vous voulez de cliver encore plus sur
ce sujet et d'opposer les vies sinois
entre eux je crois que par rapport à
l'étude qui a été fait en tout cas moi
je me prends j'ai pris le bus chinois
tels que lui sinon reçu je crois que la
pointe de la bretagne il me semble le
meilleur endroit
c'est mon point de vue cette habitation
qui par sa me sens mais en gênera en
gênera moins de gens maintenant je ris
c'est un sujet c'est un sujet sérieux
vous vous dites qu'il faut respecter les
morts je souriais voilà pour la piste
privilégiée beatrice kiraso dernière
j'allais excusez moi très rapide parce
qu'en fait la vérité c'est madame bois à
votre adjointe lors d'une commission qui
nous a dit clairement que
le champ du loup appartenait à saint
quentin en yvelines et qu'on ne pouvait
pas faire le cimetière là bas puisque
des aménagements pouvaient être
envisagées moi j'attends de savoir ce
qu'on est envisagé d'en haut champ du
loup quels sont les projets que madame
rose est idoine au frac un tour de table
béatrice s'appuiera sur le sujet du
cimetière donc j'entends ce qui est dit
autour de la table ce soir nous nous
sommes renseignés et pour nous il reste
70 places aujourd'hui au cimetière des
tilleuls sachant qu'il y a environ 15
enterrement dans la ville de
voisins-le-bretonneux par an si on fait
un calcul rapide ça nous laisse encore
un petit peu de temps pour penser sujet
parce qu'on sent bien autour de cette
table qu'il ya des tensions sur le sujet
du cimetière et qu'il ne faut en aucun
cas prendre la décision à la légère
sur la question le cimetière est aussi d
un enjeu pour le coup sur
l'environnement puisqu'il ya aussi des
il faut prendre cette thématique en
contre bien sûr bien sûr le les sujets
autour de l'environnement et l'écologie
sont très importants pour nous et comme
je le dis pour nous il est important de
tenir compte des différentes d'une part
des habitants nous poussons aussi sur
notre liste
la concertation avec les habitants j'en
parlerai dans la conclusion puisqu'il
brest ou encore et sur le sujet du
cimetière comme je les dis on a un petit
peu de temps encore pour y penser
puisque 70 / 15 ça nous fait un peu plus
de quatre ans quand même pour y
réfléchir
on a un peu plus de dix minutes encore
des missions pour aborder la dernière
thématique un coup d'oeil encore sur les
temps de parole de fne de 40 pour
alexandra rosetti cinq minutes 55 pour
béatrice pierrât olivia france vous êtes
à 10 minutes 19 le quatrième thème c'est
la santé voisins le bretonneux va faire
face à des départs à la retraite de ces
médecins généralistes ils sont dix
aujourd'hui la moitié va bientôt partir
à la retraite et ne prennent plus de
nouveaux patients je rappelle qu'il est
environ 11 milles habitants à voisins le
bretonneux quels sont vos différentes
solutions que vous comptez mettre en
place pour anticiper une éventuelle
pénurie éviter la désertification
médicale et saura aux études en fait
sauf à une compétence de la commune donc
c'est pas un sujet facile et voisins le
bretonneux n'est pas la seule ville
dans ce cas la bien nommée constitue l
attirer de jeunes médecins en tout cas
nous allons avec un promoteur privé qui
s'est engagé sur cette question la
grande île nous allons construire une
maison pluri professionnels de santé
avec un projet commun avec des
généralistes et des spécialistes en tout
cas c'est le projet de base après on va
passer on va pas se cacher que c'est
très difficile de trouver autant les
spécialistes je crois qu'il a il a
trouvé mais le généraliste est très très
difficile donc il faut attirer peut-être
des jeunes qui sortent de l'université
évidemment alors est-ce que la solution
c'est de deux salariés les médecins ça
c'est une solution qui me ferait un
petit peu peur parce que je pense qu'un
médecin ça doit être
je me fais un peu renseigné c'est dans
les 5000 euros par mois
donc ça pèse forcément même si les
revenus à côté pour la commune c'est
quand même assez cher
et puis il ya sans doute une crise aussi
la vocation des médecins je ne suis pas
sûr que les communes puissent soit à
même d'y répondre parce que voisin reste
une ville de toute façon assez
attractives agréable à vivre
mais j'avoue que sur ce sujet je pense
que c'est extrêmement complexe et que
même une maison pleurer professionnels
de santé ne résout pas tout puisque je
vois mes collègues qui ont fait un tour
ont également du mal à attirer des
médecins
béatrice ferrat sur cette thématique de
la santé de comment attirer des médecins
des jeunes médecins à voisins le
bretonneux
alors tout d'abord nous pensons que le
sujet de la santé comme l'a dit
alexandra rosetti eux dépassent le cadre
de la commune puisque nous sommes quand
même dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines et il ya des
solutions comme des maisons médicales
qui ont été développés par les villes de
guyancourt où de montigny le bretonneux
qui sont quand même ses proches de nous
ensuite nous avons vu aussi des exemples
de bourse par exemple avec des aides des
étudiants avec une contrepartie pour
s'installer dans la commune
c'est un sujet étudié est ce qu'il ya
des partenariats imaginer peut-être avec
université sur le territoire
l'université de versailles saint quentin
en yvelines qui a des études de médecine
ya des étudiants qui se forme pour
devenir médecin est ce qu'il faut
imaginer aussi des partenariats
peut-être avec cette université
peut-être à nouveau ce que nous
défendons dans notre liste c'est aussi
la concertation avec les habitants donc
voir avec les habitants s'ils ont des
pistes aussi qui leur paraissent plus
plus intéressante à développer pour ce
sujet désertification je trouve que le
terme quand même désertification quand
on est en région parisienne fin pour moi
qui viens de la province désertification
médicale pour saint quentin en yvelines
le terme est quand même peut-être un peu
fort encore le cas mais peut-être dans
l'avenir en tout cas mais effectivement
on a tous qu'il est difficile d'avoir un
médecin j'ai moi même un médecin qui a
plus de 70 ans
donc je comprends qu'elle ait le sujet
je comprends que ça peut ça peut poser
des questions on vit sinoise et ovi
chinois qui ne regarde mais la solution
doit passer par une concertation avec
l'agglomération et aussi au niveau des
arrêts sein des agences régionales des
établissement de santé pour voir comment
trouver une solution qui ne laisse
aucune partie très bien en matière de
santé ce que vous avez deux propositions
sur le thème de plus globale de la santé
pas que sur cette désertification
nous encourageons toutes là tout le
volet de la solidarité donc tout à
l'heure olivier françois a parlé des
personnes âgées
nous pensons que aussi bien pour les
personnes âgées que pour les personnes
en situation d'handicap il faut pouvoir
les intégrer au mieux dans la ville en
proposant par exemple un système pour
faciliter leur mobilité à la demande ou
également pour des personnes qui peuvent
avoir plus de difficultés pour tout ce
qui est rédaction de documents
administratifs aussi les déclarations
d'impôt qui se feront de plus en plus
sur le numérique et tout le monde n'est
pas toujours à l'aise avec cet outil du
21e siècle je dirais donc nous
souhaitons aussi mettre en place au sein
de la mairie un guichet pour aider les
personnes autour de ce thème de la
solidarité avec aussi mais je pensais en
parler en conclusion mais je vais en
parler dès maintenant la mise en place
d'une maison du savoir partagé alors
dont le nom est encore en discussion
comme je les dis on pense aussi beaucoup
à la concertation avec les habitants
mais l'idée de partager les compétences
entre les personnes et créé vraiment un
lien de solidarité et de rapprochement
puisque à voisins-le-bretonneux
contrairement à d'autres villes nous
n'avons pas de marché alors nous
souhaiterions aussi trouver une solution
pour faire venir à marcher dans la ville
pour créer un lien social et crée aussi
une vie attractive et retrouver un peu
cette ambiance de village d'en parler
olivier à france ô tout à l'heure olivia
france ô sur cette thématique alors il
ya des propositions que j'ai relevées
dans votre programme notamment créer un
pôle médical au centre village c'est ça
alors plus particulièrement pour les
seniors bien sûr je vais te répondre
elle appuiera sur sur le cimetière je
crains sincèrement qu'on soit dans une
urgence puisque vous ai dit ma démontera
pas c'est en 2021
nous avons comme échéance 2021 pour
construire le cimetière vous pouvez leur
ai abordé si vous voulez dans la
conclusion qua non sur la santé savate
insultes sur la santé on n'est pas dans
une désertification médicale
on a un risque il est identifié et pour
la première fois on anticipe c'est
plutôt une bonne chose
donc nous nous avons un petit peu
réfléchi à ce sujet qui est très
complexe je rejoins parfaitement les
propos tenus par rosetti nous voulons
créer un pôle santé et social
dans google puisqu'il va devoir discuter
de l'aménagement de cette zone
je voudrais regrouper donc les médecins
le laboratoire dans cette nouvelle
structure moderne
je souhaiterais pouvoir mettre aussi le
ccas qui a besoin aussi de structures
d'accueil
peut-être avec un peu plus de
confidentialité pour les usagers et je
retiens à votre proposition
effectivement je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec le fait qu'ils aient ce
matin même les personnes âgées qui me
l'ont dit ils n'ont qu'à voisin un lieu
qui leur permettent effectivement et les
impôts
il ya toute cette entraide là parce que
tout le monde n'est pas tout on n'est
pas au fait du numérique
vous m'avez enlever la bouche la
proposition du partenariat
effectivement nous proposons un
partenariat avec la faculté de médecine
de l'université de versailles saint
quentin
donc c'est un sujet voilà je pense que
qui fait consensus au sein de au sein
des listes il convient de regarder
attentivement qui va être tendre
conclure ce débat dernier coup d'oeil
sur les temps de parole onze minutes 0
une part alessandra rosetti 11 minutes
42 pour olivier affonso huit minutes
trente sept pour béatrice car on va
prendre le sens inverse de des prises de
parole du début de ce débat et commencé
avec vous béatrice pire à vous avez au
maximum trois minutes trente pour
conclure alors vous pouvez soit abordée
à une thématique libre qui n'a pas été
abordé au cours de ce débat ou revenir
sur quelque chose aussi que vous
souhaitiez approfondir tout à fait alors
je souhaitais aborder une thématique
libre c'est pour ça que je souhaitais
garder un petit peu de temps pour cette
conclusion parce que un des volets que
nous souhaitons mettre en avant dans
notre programme c'est la partie ville
citoyenne que nous n'avons pas beaucoup
abordé lors de nos échanges
ce que nous pensons c'est qu'aujourd'hui
il existe des conseils de quartier dans
la ville et que les conseils de quartier
doivent avoir un réel rôle de vecteur
d'informations entre les habitants
vicinaux a sévi si noir et la
municipalité que ce soit dans un sens ou
dans l'autre pour permettre de prendre
des décisions en concertation avec la
population est également de faire
remonter des problématiques qui pourrait
ne pas être reconnus au niveau de la
municipalité
un autre point que nous souhaitons
mettre en avant à travers sept
cet axe de ville citoyenne c'est ce que
nous avons appelé l'assemblée vie
sinoise pourquoi parce que notre ville
va voir différents défis à relever dans
les années qui viennent on a déjà parlé
de la ligne 18 qui va quand même
entraîné des changements assez important
dans la ville et nous pensons qu'il est
nécessaire d'avoir une structure alors
dans une forme que nous imaginons
aujourd'hui que nous appelons assemblée
vie chinoise avec un mélange d'habitants
peut-être d'élus d'experts pour
réfléchir de façon beaucoup plus
stratégique sur un terme beaucoup plus
long aujourd'hui on le voit ici avec
notre débat nos parlant de sujets du
quotidien de sujets qui vont arriver
dans les années à ses proches mais il y
a aussi des enjeux qui sont à des délais
beaucoup plus longs pour lesquels il
faut avoir une réelle réflexion et une
intégration pour éviter de prendre des
décisions au coup par coup
on parlait du cimetière une fois qu'on
implante un cimetière
il n'est pas question de le déplacer
donc là on a plusieurs centaines
d'années de cimetière donc la décision
de l'implantation d'un cimetière est une
décision qui doit être faite en
cohérence avec d'autres impacts de façon
à garantir que ça ne pénalisera pas
d'autres sujets liés à la vie alors il
vous reste une minute au choix si vous
voulez peut-être dire pourquoi on
devrait choisir les bises noah devrait
choisir votre liste vous avez à peu près
une minute encore de temps de parole où
on pourra vous donner de nouveau la
parole d'ici le 15 mars et au choix
alors je vais prendre le temps que vous
me lisez vous avez parlé davis et moi je
vais aussi ajouter les vices et noise
c'est pourquoi votre est il pour nous
parce qu'aujourd'hui nous défendons
trois axes qu'il est nous paraissent
très important en 2020 le premier axe
qui est une ville éco responsable c'est
à dire que pour nous la préoccupation
écologique est un vrai sujet nous
pensons que la ville à sa mesure doit
intervenir dans ses choix notamment sur
la rénovation des bâtiments pour
préserver la planète
le deuxième volet la ville citoyenne je
viens d'en parler juste avant et le
troisième volet une ville solidaire qui
permet à tous et toutes de s'intégrer
pleinement
la ville olivia fonso 20 30 secondes
pour vous avez beaucoup moins de temps
pour conclure ce débat ou pas renié du
cimetière je souhaiterais avoir un os
sur celui des tilleuls où le manque
d'autres d'entretien est une honte pour
la ville de voisins la ville citoyenne
j'ai l'intention si je suis maire de
voisins de chat de mettre un rapporteur
en charge de la concertation publique
qui sera issu des groupes minoritaires
en tout cas celui qui sera le moins bien
représentés je ne siègerait pas la
gloire en tant que vice président mais
en tant que maire donc je serai bien à
l'agglo mais je ne serai pas vice
président parce que j'ai une intime
conviction qu'en politique il ya ceux
qui en vivent
et ceux qui la font et je serai toujours
du côté de ceux qui la font j'ai une
équipe un projet d'accord si j'ai une
équipe
j'ai un projet je note ce soir que nous
avons des bottes des battues
essentiellement sur mes propositions
c'est très bien j'attends maintenant les
nouvelles propositions alexandra rosetti
vous avez une minute environ un peu plus
d'une minute pour achever je vais juste
répondre au petit tacle sur l'a10
présidence je pense qu'effectivement il
y a il faut avoir une certaine capacité
de travail pour avoir plusieurs
plusieurs mandats ça c'est évident puis
quand on était maman de trois enfants
qu'on les a promenés dans toute la ville
compte travailler en même temps quand on
est élu et en même temps et c'est le
boulot ça fait pas peur on a l'habitude
de se partager
et puis c'est vrai que les mandats que
j'ai eu en fait il était extrêmement
complémentaires et ils m'ont beaucoup
appris et tout ce que j'ai appris je les
mets au service de la de la commune donc
je n'ai absolument pas à en rougir et
vous voyez je ne suis absolument pas
fatigué donc ça veut dire que je gère
phare fort bien
ces trois choses moi j'ai envie d'une
énergie d'une ville c'est mon slogan
vous énergie positive c'est-à-dire que
venir dire que le cadre de vie se
détériorent venu dire que le cimetière
et mal entretenu alors que nous avons
constamment des compliments que quand
nous ouvrons des portes encore il ya
deux jours chez le vétérinaire une dame
qui ne me connaît pas qui me dit voisin
est très propre
vous voyez donc comme quoi c'est pas
parce que vous passez dans les foyers
pour dire que tout va mal que tout va
mal
donc je suis plutôt rassuré des retours
que nous avons et je compte bien
continuer sur cette lancée
améliorer encore ce qui peut l'être bien
entendu et puis pour répondre aussi à ce
que vous dites nous parle même plus de
démocratie participative on parle de
démocratie implique hâtives
parce que ça nous semble essentiel et on
l'a démontré et en particulier avec le
travail que nous avons soutenue du
conseil de quartier sur la
circulation qui produira des solutions
que c'est comme ça que voisin réussir à
rester attractive on va s'arrêter là
pour le débat le débat qui touche à sa
fin on jette un coup d'oeil aux temps de
parole pour voir que béatrice pire à
vous avez environ une minute de retard
sur le temps de parole
il y aura du temps un pur et équilibré
d'ici le premier tour des élections
municipales qui est programmé je le
rappelle le 15 mars prochain
merci de nous avoir suivis pour ce débat
qui était diffusée sur tv 78 radio
sensations yvelines il est bien sûr à
retrouver en replay sur tv 78 points
comme les débats et du scrutin des
municipales vont continuer sur ces deux
antennes tv 78 et radio sensations et
vinh
[Musique]